The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So
yes, before we start,
this chapter will not
be part of the midterm.
Everything else will be, so all
the way up to goodness of fit
tests.
And there will be
some practice exams
that will be posted
in the recitation
section of the course.
And that will be--
you will be working on.
So the recitation tomorrow
will be a review session
for the midterm.
I'll send an
announcement by email.
So going back to
our estimator, we
showed that the least
squares estimator in the case
where we had some
Gaussian observations.
So we had something that
looked like this-- y was
equal to some matrix x times
beta plus some epsilon.
This was an equation
that was happening in r
to the n for n observations.
And then we wrote the least
squares estimator beta hat.
And for the purpose
from here on,
you see that you have
this normal distribution,
this Gaussian p
variant distribution.
That means that, at
some point, we've
made the assumption
that epsilons
were n and dimensional
0 identity of rn
times sigma squared,
which I kept
on forgetting about last time.
I will try not to
do that this time.
And so from this,
we derived a bunch
of properties of this least
squares estimator, beta hat.
And in particular, the key thing
that everything was built on
was that we could write beta
hat as the true unknown beta
plus some multivariate
Gaussian that was centered,
but had a weird
covariant structure.
So that was definitely
p dimensional.
And it was sigma
squared times x--
so that's x transpose x.
And that's inverse.
And the way we derived that
was by having a lot of--
at least one cancellation
between x transpose x and x
transpose x inverse.
So this is the basis for
inference in linear regression.
So in a way, that's
correct, because what
happened is that we used
the fact that x beta hat--
once we have this
beta, x beta hat
is really just a projection
of y onto the linear span
of the columns of x, or
the column span of x.
And so in particular,
those things--
y minus x beta hats--
are called residuals.
So that's the
vector of residuals.
What's the dimension
of this vector?
AUDIENCE: n by 1.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: n by 1.
So those things, we can
write as epsilon hat.
There's an estimate
for this epsilon
because we just
put a hat on beta.
And from this one,
we could actually
build an unbiased estimator
of sigma hat squared,
and that was this guy.
And we showed that, indeed, the
right normalization for this
was n minus p, because y
minus x beta hat to norm
is actually a chi squared with
n minus p degrees of freedom.
And so that's up to this
scaling by sigma squared.
So that's what we came up with.
And something I told
you, which follows
from Cochran's theorem--
we did not go into
details about this.
But essentially,
since one of them
corresponds to projection onto
the linear span of the columns
of x, and the other one
corresponds to projection
onto the orthogonal of this guy,
and we're in a Gaussian case,
things that are
orthogonal are actually
independent in a Gaussian case.
So from a geometric
point of view,
you can sort of
understand everything.
You think of your subspace of
the linear span of the x's,
sometimes you project
onto this guy,
onto its orthogonal.
Beta hat corresponds
to projection
onto the linear span.
Epsilon hats correspond to a
projection onto the orthogonal.
And those things tend
to be independent,
and that's what you
have that beta hat
is independent of
sigma hat squared.
So it's really just a statement
about two linear spaces being
orthogonal with
respect to each other.
So we left on this
slide last time.
And what I claim is that
this thing here is actually--
oh, yeah-- the other
thing we want to use.
So that's good for beta hat.
But since we don't know
what sigma squared is--
if we knew what
sigma squared is,
that would totally
be enough for us.
But we also need
this extra thing--
that sigma squared hat squared
over sigma squared follows--
and there's an n minus p.
This follows a chi squared with
n minus p degrees of freedom.
And sigma hat squared is
independent of beta hat.
So that's going to
be something we need.
So that's useful if
sigma squared if unknown.
And again, sometimes
it might be known
if you're using some sort
of measurement device
for which it's written
on the side of the box.
So from these two
things, we're going
to be able to do inference
And inference, we
said there's three
pillars to inference.
The first one is estimation, and
we've been doing that so far.
We've constructed this
least squares estimator,
which happens to be
the maximum likelihood
estimator in the Gaussian case.
The two other things
we do in inference
are confidence intervals.
And we can do
confidence intervals.
We're not going to
do much because we're
going to talk about their sort
of cousin, which are tests.
And that's really where
the statistical inference
comes into.
And here, we're going to
be interested in a very
specific kind of test
for linear regression.
And those are tests
of the form beta j--
so the j-th coefficient
of beta is equal to 0,
and that's going to be our null
hypothesis, versus h1 where
beta j is, say, not equal to 0.
And for the purpose
of regression,
unless you have lots of
domain-specific knowledge,
it won't be beta j positive
or beta j negative.
It's really non-0 that's
interesting to you.
So why would I want
to do this test?
Well, if I expand this
thing where I have y
is equal to x beta
plus epsilon--
so what happens if
I look, for example,
at the first coordinates?
So I have that y is actually--
so say, y1 is equal to beta 1
plus beta 2 x 1.
Well, that's
actually complicated.
Let me write it like this--
beta 0 plus beta 1 x1 plus
beta p minus 1 xp minus 1
plus epsilon.
And that's true for all i's.
So this is beta 1 times 1.
That was our first coordinate.
So that's just expanding this--
going back to the
scalar form rather than
going to the matrix vector form.
That's what we're doing.
When I write y is equal
to x beta plus epsilon,
I assume that each of my
y's can be represented
as a linear combination
of the x's, the first one
being 1 plus some epsilon i.
Everybody agrees with this?
What does it mean for
beta j to be equal to 0?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That
xj's not important.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
that xj doesn't even
show up in this thing.
So if beta j is equal to 0,
that means that, essentially, we
can remove the j's coordinate,
xj, from all observations.
So for example, I'm
a banker, and I'm
trying to predict some score--
let's call it y--
without the noise.
So I'm trying to predict what
is going to be your score.
And that's something
that should be telling me
how likely you are to
reimburse your loan on time
or do you have late payments.
Or actually, maybe
these days bankers
are actually looking at
how much late fees will I
be collecting from you.
Maybe that's what they are more
after rather than making sure
that you reimburse everything.
So they're trying to maximize
this number of late fees.
And they collect a bunch
of things about you--
definitely your credit
score, but maybe your
zip code, profession, years
of education, family status,
a bunch of things.
One might be your shoe size.
And they want to know--
maybe shoe is actually
a good explanation
for how much fees
they're going to be
collecting from you.
But as you can imagine, this
would be a controversial thing
to bring, and people might
want to test for their shoe
size is a good idea.
And so they would just
look at the j corresponding
to shoe size and test whether
shoe size should appear or not
in this formula.
And that's essentially
the kind of thing
that people are going to do.
Now, if I do genomics
and I'm trying
to predict the size, the girth,
of a pumpkin for a competition
based on some
available genomic data,
then I can test whether
gene j, which is called--
I don't know-- pea snap 24--
they always have these crazy
names--
appears or not in this formula.
Is the gene pea snap 24
going to be important or not
for the size of
the final pumpkin?
So those are definitely
the important things.
And definitely, we
want to put beta j not
equal to 0 as the alternative
because that's where
scientific discovery shows up.
And so to do that, well,
we're in a Gaussian set-up,
so we know that even if we
don't know what sigma hat is,
we can actually
call for a t-test.
So how did we build
the t-test in general?
Well, we had something that
looked like-- so before, what
we had was something that
looked like theta hat was
equal to theta plus some
n0 and something that
depended on n, maybe, something
like this-- sigma squared
over n.
So that's what it looked like.
Now what we have
is that beta hat
is equal to beta plus some n,
but this time, it's p variant,
and then x transpose x
inverse sigma squared.
So it's actually very similar,
except that the matrix
x transpose x inverse
is now replacing
just this number, 1/n, but
it's playing the same role.
So in particular, this implies
that for every j from 1
to p, what is the
distribution of beta hat j?
Well, beta hat j is
actually equal to--
so all I have to do-- so this
is a system of p equations,
and all I have to do is
to read the j through.
So it's telling me here, I'm
going to read beta hat j.
Here, I'm going to read beta j.
And here, I need
to read, what is
the distribution of the j-th
coordinates of this guy?
So this is a Gaussian
vector, so we
need to understand
what its definition is.
So how do I do this?
Well, the observation that's
actually useful for this--
maybe I shouldn't use the word
observation in a stats class,
so let's call it claim.
The interesting claim is
that if I have a vector--
let's call it v--
then vj is equal to
v transpose ej where
ej is the vector with 0, 0,
0, and then the 1 on the j-th
coordinate, and
then 0 elsewhere.
That's the j-th coordinate.
So that's the j-th vector of
the canonical basis of rp.
So now that I have
this form, I can
see that, essentially,
beta hat j
is just ej transpose
this np0 sigma squared
x transpose x inverse.
And now, I know what
the distribution
of the inner product
between a Gaussian
and a deterministic vector is.
What is it?
It's a Gaussian.
So all I have to check is that
ej transpose np0 sigma squared
x transpose x inverse--
well, this is equal in
distribution to what?
Well, this is going to be
a one-dimensional thing.
A then your product
is just a real number.
So it's going to
be some Gaussian.
The mean is going to be 0 in
a product with ej, which is 0.
What is the variance
of this guy?
We actually used this, except
that ej was not a vector,
but it was a matrix.
So what we do is we, to see--
so the rule is that v transpose,
say, n mu sigma is
some n v transpose mu,
and then v transpose
sigma v. That's
the rule for Gaussian vectors.
There's just the property
of Gaussian vectors.
So what do we have here?
Well, ej plays the
role of v. And sigma
squared x transpose x
inverse is the role of sigma.
So here, I'm left
with ej transpose--
let me pull out the
sigma squared here.
But this thing is, what
happens if I take a matrix,
I premultiply it
by this vector ej,
and I postmultiply
it by this vector ej?
I'm claiming that this
corresponds to only one
single element of this matrix.
Which one is it?
AUDIENCE: j.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
j's diagonal element.
So this thing here is nothing
but x transpose x inverse,
and then the j-th
diagonal element is jj.
Now, I cannot go any further.
x transpose x inverse can
be a complicated matrix,
and I do not know how to express
jj's diagonal element much
better than this.
Well, no, actually, I don't.
It involves basically
all the coefficients.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
second j come from,
so I get why ej
transpose [INAUDIBLE]..
Where did the--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
From this rule?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So you always pre-
and postmultiply when you
talk about the covariance,
because if you did not, it would
be a vector and not a scalar,
for one.
But in general, think
of v as a matrix.
It's still true even
in v is a matrix that's
compatible with
the premultiplying
by some Gaussian.
Any other question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you say claim
a vector v, what is vector v?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So for any vector v--
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Any other question?
So now we've identified
that the j-th coefficient
of this Gaussian, which I
can represent from the claim
as ej transpose
this guy, is also
a Gaussian that's centered.
And its variance,
now, is sigma squared
times the j-th diagonal element
of x transpose x inverse.
So the conclusion
is that beta hat j
is equal to beta j plus some n.
And I'm going to emphasize
the fact that now it's
one-dimensional with mean 0
and covariance sigma squared x
transpose x inverse inverse jj.
Now, if you look at the last
line of the second board
and the first line
on the first board,
those are basically
the same thing.
Beta hat j is my theta hat.
Beta j is my theta.
And the variance
sigma squared over n
is now sigma squared times
this [? jj's ?] element.
Now, the inverse suggests that
it looks like the inverse of n.
So those things are going to--
we're going to want
to think of those guys
as being some sort of
1/n kind of statement.
So from this, the fact that
those two things are the same
leads us to believe
that we are now
equipped to perform the task
that we're trying to do,
because under the
null hypothesis,
beta j is known it's equal
to 0, so I can remove it.
And I have to deal
with the sigma squared.
If sigma squared
is known, then I
can just perform
a regular Gaussian
test using Gaussian quintiles.
And if sigma squared
is unknown, I'm
going to just divide
by sigma squared
and multiply by sigma
hat, and then I'm
going to basically
get my t-test.
Actually, for the
purpose of your exam,
I really suggest that you
understand every single word
I'm going to be saying now,
because this is exactly
the same thing that
you're expected
to know from other courses,
because right now, I'm just
going to apply exactly
the same technique that we
did for the single
parameter estimation.
So what do we have now is that
under h0, beta j is equal to 0.
Therefore, beta hat j follows
some n0 sigma squared.
Just like I do in the slide,
I'm going to call this gamma j.
So gamma j is this x transpose
x inverse j-th diagonal element.
So that implies that
beta hat j over sigma--
oh, was it a square root?
Yeah, sigma square root of
gamma j follows some n0 1.
So I can form my
test statistic, which
to be reject if the absolute
value of beta hat j divided
by sigma square root gamma
j is larger than what?
Can somebody tell
me what I want this
to be larger than to reject?
AUDIENCE: q alpha.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: q alpha.
Everybody agrees?
Of what?
Of this guy, where
the standard notation
that this is the quintile.
Everybody agrees?
AUDIENCE: It's alpha
over 2 I think.
I think alpha's--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Alpha over 2.
So not everybody
should be agreeing.
Thank you, you're the first
one to disagree with yourself,
which is probably good.
It's alpha over 2 because
of the absolute value.
I want to just be
away from this guy,
and that's because I have--
so the alpha over 2--
the sanity check should be that
h1 is beta j not equal to 0.
So that works if sigma is known,
because I need to know sigma
to be able to build my test.
So if sigma is unknown, well,
I can tell you, use this test,
but you're going to
be like, OK, when
I'm going to have to
plug in some numbers,
I'm going to be stuck.
But if sigma is unknown,
we have sigma hat
squared as an estimator.
So let me write
sigma squared here.
So in particular,
beta hat divided
by sigma hat squared times
square root gamma j-- something
I can compute.
Sorry, that's beta hat j.
I can compute that thing.
Agreed?
Now I have sigma hat j.
What I need to do is
to be able to compute
the distribution of this thing.
So I know the distribution of
beta hat j over the square root
of gamma j.
That's some Gaussian 0, 1.
I don't know exactly what
the distribution of sigma hat
j squared is, but what I know is
that that was actually written,
maybe, here is that n minus p
sigma hat squared over sigma
squared follows some chi
squared with n minus p
degrees of freedom,
and that it's actually
independent of beta hat j.
It's independent of
beta hat, so it's
independent of each
of its coordinates.
That was part of your
homework where you had to--
some of you were confused
by the fact that--
I mean, if you're independent
of some big thing,
you're independent
of all the smaller
components of this big thing.
That's basically what
you need to know.
And so now I can
just write this as--
this is beta hat j divided by--
so now I want to
make this guy appear,
so it's beta hat j sigma
squared over sigma squared--
sigma hat squared over sigma
squared times n minus p divided
by the square root of gamma j.
So that's what I want to see.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why do
you have to stick
the hat in the denominator?
Shouldn't it be sigma?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, so I write this.
I decide to write this.
I could have put a
Mickey Mouse here.
It just wouldn't make sense.
I just decided to
take this thing.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: OK.
So now, let-- so I
take this guy, and now,
I'm going to rewrite
it as something I want,
because if you don't
know what sigma is--
sorry, that's not sigm--
you mean the square?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Oh, thank you.
Yes, that's correct.
[LAUGHS] OK, so you
don't know what's sigma
is, you replace it by sigma hat.
That's the most
natural thing to do.
You just now want
to find out what
the distribution of this guy is.
So this is not
exactly what I had.
To be able to get this, I need
to divide by sigma squared--
sorry, I need to--
AUDIENCE: Square root.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Do we
need a square root
of the sigma hat [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
That's correct now.
And now I have that--
sorry, I should not
write it like that.
That's not what I want.
What I want is this.
And to be able to get
this guy, what I need
is sigma over sigma
hat square root.
And then I need to make
this thing show up.
So I need to have this n minus
p show up in the denominator.
So to be able to get
it, I need to multiply
the entire thing by the
square root of n minus p.
So this is just a tautology.
I just squeezed
in what I wanted.
But now this whole thing
here, this is actually
of the form beta hat j divided
by sigma over square root gamma
j, and then divided by square
root of sigma hat squared
over sigma squared.
No, I don't want to divide it by
square root of minus p, sorry.
And now it's times n minus
p divided by n minus p.
And what is the distribution
of this thing here?
So I'm going to keep going here.
So the distribution of
this thing here is what?
Well, this numerator,
what is this distribution?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, n0 1.
It's actually still
written over there.
So that's our n0 1.
What is the distribution
of this guy?
Sorry, I don't think
you have color again.
So what is the
distribution of this guy?
This is still
written on the board.
AUDIENCE: Chi squared.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: It's the chi
squared that I have right here.
So that's a chi squared n
minus p divided by n minus p
degrees of freedom.
The only thing I
need to check is
that those two guys
are independent, which
is also what I have from here.
And so that implies
that beta hat j divided
by sigma hat square
root of gamma
j, what is the
distribution of this guy?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: n minus p.
Was that crystal
clear for everyone?
Was that so simple that
it was boring to everyone?
OK, good.
That's where the point
at which you should be.
So now I have this, I can read
the quintiles of this guy.
So my test statistic becomes--
well, my rejection
region, I reject
if the absolute
value of this new guy
exceeds the quintile of order
alpha over 2, but this time,
of a tn minus p.
And now you can actually
see that the only difference
between this test and that
test, apart from replacing sigma
by sigma hat, is
that now I've moved
from the quintiles of a
Gaussian to the quintiles
of a tn minus p.
What's actually interesting,
from this perspective,
is that the tn minus
p, we know, has
heavier tails than the Gaussian,
but if the number of degrees
of freedom reaches, maybe, 30 or
40, they're virtually the same.
And here, the number
of degrees of freedom
is not given only by
n, but it's n minus p.
So if I have more and more
parameters to estimate,
this will result in some
heavier, heavier tails,
and that's just to
account for the fact
that it's harder and harder
to estimate the variance
when I have a lot of parameters.
That's basically where
it's coming from.
So now let's move on to--
well, I don't know what because
this is not working anymore.
So this is the simplest test.
And actually, if you run
any statistical software
for least squares, the
output in any of them
will look like this.
You will have a
sequence of rows.
And you're going to have
an estimate for beta 0,
an estimate for
beta 1, et cetera.
Here, you're going to
have a bunch of things.
And on this row, you're
going to have the value here,
so that's going to be what's
estimated by least squares.
And then the second line
immediately is going to be,
well, either the
value of this thing--
so let's call it t.
And then there's going
to be the p value
corresponding to this t.
This is something that's just
routinely coming out because--
oh, and then there's, of course,
the last line for people who
cannot read numbers that's
really just giving you little
stars.
They're not stickers,
but that's close to it.
And that's just saying,
well, I have three stars,
I'm very significantly
different from 0's.
If I have 2 stars, I'm
moderately differently from 0.
And if I have 1 star,
it means, well, just
give me another $1,000 and I
will sign that it's actually
different from 0.
So that's basically
the kind of outputs.
Everybody sees what
I mean by that?
So what I mean, what I'm
trying to emphasize here,
is that those things
are so routine when
you run linear aggression,
because people stuff in maybe--
even if you have
200 observations,
you're going to stuff in maybe
20 variables-- p equals 20.
That's still a big number to
interpret what's going on.
And it's nice for you if you
can actually trim some fat out.
And so the problem is that when
you start doing this, and then
this, and then
this, and then this,
the probability that
you make a mistake
in your test, the probably
that you erroneously
reject the null here is 5%.
Here, it's 5%.
And at some point, if things
happen with 5% chances
and you keep on doing
them over and over again,
they're going to
start to happen.
So you can see that
basically what's happening
is that you actually
have an issue is
that if you start
repeating those tests,
you might not be at 5%
error at some point.
And so what do you do
to prevent from that,
if you want to test all those
beta j's simultaneously,
you have to do what's called
the Bonferroni correction.
And the Bonferroni correction
follows from what's
called a union bound.
A union bound is actually-- so
if you're a computer scientist,
you're very familiar with it.
If you're a mathematician,
that's just, essentially,
the third axiom of
probability that you see,
that the probability
of the union
is less than the sum
of the probabilities.
That's the union bound.
And you, of course, can
generalize that to more than 2.
And that's exactly
what you're doing here.
So let's see how we would
want to perform Bonferroni
correction to control the
probability that they're all
equal to 0 at the same time.
So recall-- so if I want to
perform this test over there
where I want to
test h0, that beta j
is equal to 0 for all
j in some subset s.
So think of s included in 1p.
You can think of it as being
all of 1 of p if you want.
It really doesn't matter. s is
something that's given to you.
Maybe you want to test
the subset of them,
but maybe you want
to test all of them.
Versus h1, beta j is not
equal to 0 for some j in s.
That's a test that tests
all these things at once.
And if you actually look
at this table all at once,
implicitly, you're performing
this test for all of the rows,
for s equal 1 to p.
You will do that.
Whether you like it
or not, you will.
So now let's look at what the
probability of type I error
looks like.
So I want the probability
of type 1 error,
so that's the probably
when h0 is true.
Well, so let me call psi j the
indicator that, say, beta j
hat over sigma hat square
root gamma j exceeds
q alpha over 2 of tn minus p.
So we know that those are
the tests that I perform.
Here, I just add
this extra index j
to tell me that I'm actually
testing the j-th coefficient.
So what I want is the
probability that under the null
so that those are all
equal to 0 that beta j's--
that I will reject to the
alternative for one of them.
So that's psi 1 is
equal to 1 or psi 2
is equal to 1, all
the way to psi--
well, let's just say that
this is the entire thing,
because it's annoying.
I mean, you can check
the slide if you
want to do it more generally.
But psi p is equal to--
or, or-- everybody agrees
that this is the probability
of type I error?
So either I reject
this one, or this one,
or this one, or this
one, or this one.
And that's exactly when I'm
going to reject at least one
of them.
So this is the probability
of type I error.
And what I want is to keep
this guy less than alpha.
But what I know is to
control the probability
that this guy is less than
alpha, that this guy is
less than alpha, that this
guy is less than alpha.
In particular, if all
these guys are disjoint,
then this could really be the
sum of all these probabilities.
So in the worst case, if psi j
equals 1 intersected with psi k
equals 1 is the empty
set, so that means
those are called disjoint sets.
You've seen this terminology
in probability, right?
So if those sets are
disjoint, for all of them,
for all j different from
k, then this probability--
well, let me write it as star--
then star is equal to, well,
the probability under h0
that psi 1 is equal to 1
plus the probability under h0
that psi p is equal to 1.
Now, if I use this test
with this alpha here,
then this probability
is equal to alpha.
This probability is
also equal to alpha.
So the probably of type I error
is actually not equal to alpha.
It's equal to?
AUDIENCE: p alpha.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: p alpha.
So what is the solution here?
Well, it's to run those
guys not with alpha,
but with alpha over p.
And if they do this, then this
guy is equal to alpha over p,
this guy is equal
to alpha over p.
And so when I get
those things, I
get p times alpha over
p, which is just alpha.
So all I do is, rather than
running each of the tests
with probability of error--
so that's a test at
level alpha over p.
That's actually very stringent.
If you think about
it for 1 second,
even if you have only 5
variables-- p equals 5--
and you started
with the tests, you
wanted to do your tests at 5%.
It forces you to do the test at
1% for each of those variables.
If you have 10
variables, I mean, that
start to be very stringent.
So it's going to be
harder and harder for you
to conclude to the alternative.
Now, one thing I
need to tell you
is that here I said,
if they are disjoint,
then those
probabilities are equal.
But if they are not
disjoint, the union bound
tells me that the
probability of the union
is less than the sum
of the probabilities.
And so now I'm not
exactly equal to alpha,
but I'm bounded by alpha.
And that's why
Bonferroni correction,
people are not super
comfortable with,
is because, in reality,
you never think
that those tests are
going to be giving you
completely disjoint things.
I mean, why would it be?
Why would it be that if
this guy is equal to 1,
then all the other
ones are equal to 0?
Why would it make any sense?
So this is definitely
conservative,
but the problem is that we don't
know how to do much better.
I mean, we have a
formula that tells you
the probability of the
union as some crazy sum that
looks at all the intersection
and all these little things.
I mean, it's the
generalization of p of a or b
is equal to p of a plus
p of b minus probability
of the intersection.
But if you start doing
this for more than 2,
it's super complicated.
The number of terms
grows really fast.
But most importantly,
even if you go here,
you still need to
control the probability
of the intersection.
And those tests are not
necessarily independent.
If they were independent,
then that would be easy.
The probably of the intersection
would be the product
of the probabilities.
But those things are
super correlated,
and so it doesn't really help.
And so we'll see, when we talk
about high-dimensional stats
towards the end, that
there's something
called false discovery rate,
which is essentially saying,
listen, if I want to
control this thing,
if I really define my
probability of type I
error as this, I want to
make sure that I never make
this kind of error, I'm doomed.
This is just not
going to happen.
But I can revise what my
goals are in terms of errors
that I make, and then I
will actually be able to do.
And what people are looking
at is false discovery rate.
And this is called
family-wise error rate, which
is a stronger thing to control.
So this trick that
consists in replacing
alpha by alpha over
the number of times
you're going to be
performing your test,
or alpha over the number
of terms in your union,
is actually called the
Bonferroni correction.
And that's something you use
when you have what's called--
another key word here
is multiple testing,
when you're trying to do
multiple tests simultaneously.
And if s is not of
p, well, you just
divide by the number of tests
that you are actually making.
So if s is of size k
for some k less than p,
you just divide alpha by
k and not by p, of course.
I mean, you can
always divide by p,
but you're going to make your
life harder for no reason.
Any question about
Bonferroni correction?
So one thing that is
maybe not as obvious
as the test beta j equal to 0
versus beta j not equal to 0--
and in particular,
what it means is
that it's not going to come
up as a software output
without even you requesting
it because this is so standard
that it's just coming out.
But there's other
tests that you might
think of that might be
more complicated and more
tailored to your
particular problem.
And those tests are of
the form g times beta
is equal to some lambda.
So let's see, the
test we've just done,
beta j equals 0 versus
beta j not equal to 0,
is actually equivalent to
ej transpose beta equals
0 versus ej transpose
beta not equal to 0.
That was our claim.
But now I don't
have to stop here.
I don't have to
multiply by a vector
and test if it's equal to 0.
I can actually replace this
by some general matrix g
and replace this guy by
some general vector lambda.
And I'm not telling
you what the dimensions
are because they're general.
I can take whatever I want.
Take your favorite
matrix, as long
as the right side of the
matrix can be multiplying beta,
and lambda, take it as
the number of rows of g,
and then you can do that.
I can always
formulate this test.
What will this test encompass?
Well, those are
kind of weird tests.
So you can think
of things like, I
want to test if beta 2 plus beta
3 are equal to 0, for example.
Maybe I want to test if beta 5
minus 2 beta 6 is equal to 23.
Well, that's weird.
But why would you want to
test if beta 2 plus beta 3
is equal to 0?
Maybe you don't want to
know if the-- you know
that the effect of
some gene is not 0.
Maybe you know that this
gene affects this trait,
but you want to know if
the effect of this gene
is canceled by the
effect of that gene.
And this is the kind
of stuff that you're
going to be testing for that.
Now, this guy is
much more artificial,
and I don't have a bedtime
story to tell you around this.
So those things can happen and
can be much more complicated.
Now, here, notice
that the matrix g
has one row for both
of the examples.
But if I want to test if
those two things happen
at the same time, then I
actually can take a matrix.
Another matrix
that can be useful
is g equals the identity of
rp and lambda is equal to 0.
What am I doing
here in this case?
What is this test testing?
Sorry, this test.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Whether
or not beta is 0.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, we're
testing if the entire vector
beta is equal to 0, because g
times beta is equal to beta,
and we're asking
whether it's equal to 0.
So the thing is, when
you want to actually test
if beta is equal to
0, you're actually
testing if your entire
model, everything you're
doing in life, is just junk.
This is just telling
you, actually,
forget about this y is
x beta plus epsilon.
y is really just epsilon.
There's nothing.
There's just some big noise
with some big variants,
and there's nothing else.
So turns out that the
statistical software
output that I wrote here spits
out an answer to this question.
Just the last line,
usually, is doing this test.
Does your model even make sense?
And it's probably for people
to check whether they actually
just mix their two data sets.
Maybe they're actually
trying to predict--
I don't know-- some credit
score from genomic data,
and so just want to
make sure, maybe, that's
not the right thing.
So it turns out that the
machinery is exactly the same
as the one we've just taken.
So we actually start from here.
So let me pull this up.
So we start from here.
Beta hat was equal to
beta plus this guy.
And the first thing we
did was to say, well,
beta j is equal to this thing
because, well, beta j was
just ej times beta.
So rather than taking ej
here, let me just take g.
Now, we said that
for any vector--
well, that was trivial.
So the thing we need to
know is, what is this thing?
Well, this thing here,
what is this guy?
It's also normal
and the mean is 0.
Again, that's just using
properties of Gaussian vectors.
And what is the
covariance matrix?
Let's call these guys sigma so
that you can make an answer,
you can formulate an answer.
So what is the
distribution of-- what
is the covariance of g
times some Gaussian 0 sigma?
AUDIENCE: g sigma g transpose.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: g
sigma g transpose, right?
So that's gx transpose
x inverse g transpose.
Now, I'm not going to be
able to go much farther.
I mean, I made this
very acute observation
that ej transpose the matrix
times ej is the j-th angle
element.
Now, if I have a general matrix,
the price to pay is that I
cannot just shrink this thing
any further because I'm trying
to be abstract.
And so I'm almost there.
The only thing that
happened last time
is that when this
was ej under h0, 0,
we knew that this was
equal to 0 under the null.
But under the null,
what is this equal to?
AUDIENCE: Lambda.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Lambda, which I know.
I mean, I wrote my thing.
And in the couple instances
I just showed you,
including this one over there
on top, lambda was equal to 0.
But in general, it
can be any lambda.
But what's key about this lambda
is that I actually know it.
That's the hypothesis
I'm formulating.
So now I'm going to have to
be a little more careful when
I want to build the
distribution of g beta hat.
I need to actually
subtract this lambda.
So now we go from
this, and we say,
well, g beta hat
minus lambda follows
some np0 sigma squared
g x transpose x
inverse g transpose.
So that's true.
Let's assume-- let's go
straight to the case when
we don't know what sigma is.
So what I'm going
to be interested in
is g beta hat minus lambda
divided by sigma hat.
And that's going to follow some
Gaussian that has this thing,
gx transpose x
inverse g transpose.
So now, what did I do last time?
So clearly, the quintiles
of this distribution
is-- well, OK, what is the
size of this distribution?
Well, I need to tell
you that g is an--
what did I take here?
AUDIENCE: 1 divided by
sigma, not sigma hat.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh,
yeah, you're right.
So let me write it like this.
Well, let me write
it like this--
sigma squared over sigma.
So let's forget about
the size of g now.
Let's just think
of any general g.
When g was a vector,
what was nice
is that this guy was just the
scalar number, just one number.
And so if I wanted to get rid
of this in the right-hand side,
all I had to do was to
divide it by this thing.
We called it gamma j.
And we just had to divide
by square root of gamma j,
and that would be gone.
Now I have a matrix.
So I need to get
rid of this matrix
somehow because, clearly, the
quintiles of this distribution
are not going to be
written in the back
of a book for any value
of g and any value of x.
So I need to standardize
before I can read anything out
of a table.
So how do we do it?
Well, we just form
this guy here.
So what we know is that if--
so here's the claim,
again, another
claim about Gaussian vector.
If x follows some n0 sigma,
then x transpose sigma inverse x
follows some chi squared.
And here, it's going to depend
on what is the dimension here.
So if I make this a k by k, a
k-dimensional Gaussian vector,
this is x squared k.
Where have we used that before?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Wald's test.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Wald's test,
that's exactly what we used.
Wald's test had a chi
squared that was showing up.
And the way we
made it show up was
by taking the
asymptotic variance,
taking its inverse, which, in
this framework, was called--
AUDIENCE: Fisher.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Fisher information.
And then we pre- and
postmultiply by this thing.
So this is the key.
And so now, it tells
me exactly, when
I start from this guy that has
this multivariate Gaussian,
it tells me how to
turn it into something
that has a distribution
which is pivotal.
Chi squared k is completely
pivotal, does not depend
on anything I don't know.
The way I go from here
is by saying, well, now,
I look at g beta hat
minus lambda transpose,
and now I need to
look at the inverse
of the matrix over there.
So it's gx transpose x
inverse g inverse g beta
hat minus lambda.
This guy is going to follow--
well, here, I need to actually
divide by sigma in this case--
if g is k times p.
So what I mean here is
just that's the same k.
The k that shows up is
the number of constraints
that I have in my tests.
So now, if I go from
here to using sigma hat,
the key thing to observe is
that this guy is actually
not a Gaussian.
I'm not going to have a student
t-distribution that shows up.
So that implies that if
I take the same thing,
so now I just go from
sigma to sigma hat,
then this thing is of the form--
well, this chi squared k divided
by the chi squared that shows
up in the denominator
of the t-distribution,
which is square root of--
oh, I should not
divide by sigma--
so this is sigma squared, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So
this is sigma squared.
So this is of the form
divided by chi squared n
minus p divided by n minus p.
So that's the same denominator
that I saw in my t-test.
The numerator has
changed, though.
The numerator is now this
chi squared and no longer
a Gaussian.
But this distribution is
actually pivotal, as long
as we can guarantee
that there's no hidden
parameter in the correlation
between the two chi squares.
So again, as all statements
of independence in this class,
I will just give
it to you for free.
Those two things, I claim--
so OK, let's say admit
these are independent.
We're almost there.
This could be a
distribution that's pivotal.
But there's something that's
a little unbalanced with it
is that this guy is divided
by its number of degrees
of freedom, but this guy is
not divided by its number
of degrees of freedom.
And so we just have
to make the extra step
that if I divide this guy by k,
and this guy is a chi squared
divided by k, if I
divide this guy by k,
then I get this
guy divided by k.
And now it looks--
I mean, it doesn't
change anything.
I've just divided
by a fixed number.
But it just looks more elegant--
is the ratio of
two independent chi
squared that are
individually divided
by the number of
degrees of freedom.
And this has a name,
and it's called a Fisher
or F-distribution.
So unlike William
Gosset, who was not
allowed to use his own name
and used the name student,
Fisher was allowed
to use his own name,
and that's called the
Fisher distribution.
And the Fisher distribution
has now 2 parameters,
a set of 2 degrees of freedom--
1 for the numerator and
1 for the denominator.
So F- of Fisher distribution--
so F is equal to the
ratio of a chi squared p/p
and a chi squared q/q.
So that's Fpq P-q where the 2
chi squareds are independent.
Is that clear what
I'm defining here?
So this is basically what plays
the role of t-distributions
when you're testing more
than 1 parameter at a time.
So you basically replace--
the normal that was
in the numerator,
you replace it by chi
squared because you're
testing if 2 vectors are
simultaneously close.
And the way you do it is by
looking at their squared norm.
And that's how the
chi squared shows up.
Quick remark-- are those
things really very different?
How can I relate a chi
squared with a t-distribution?
Well, if t follows, say, a t--
I don't know, let's call it q.
So that means that
t, let me look at--
t is some n01 divided by
the square root of a chi
squared q/q.
That's the distribution of t.
So if I look at the square of
the-- the distribution of t
squared--
let me put it here--
well, that's the square of some
n01 divided by chi squared q/q.
Agreed?
I just removed the
square root here,
and I took the square
of the Gaussian.
But what is the distribution
of a square of a Gaussian?
AUDIENCE: Chi squared
with 1 degree.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Chi squared
with 1 degree of freedom.
So this is a chi squared
And in particular,
it's also a chi
squared with 1 degree
of freedom divided by 1.
So t-squared, in the end,
has an F-distribution with 1
and q degrees of freedom.
So those two things are
actually very similar.
The only thing that's
going to change
is that, since we're actually
looking at, typically,
absolute values of t
when we do our tests,
it's going to be
exactly the same thing.
These quintiles of
one guy are going
to be, essentially, the
square root of the quintiles
of the other guy.
That's all it's going to be.
So if my test is psi is
equal to the indicator
that t exceeds q alpha
over 2 of tq, for example,
then it's equal to the
indicator that t-squared
exceeds q squared
alpha over 2 tq,
because I had the
absolute value here,
which is equal to the
indicator that t squared is
greater than q alpha over 2.
And now this time, it's an F1q.
So in a way, those two things
belong to the same family.
They really are a natural
generalization of each other.
I mean, at least the F-test is
a generalization of the t-test.
And so now I can perform my test
just like it's written here.
I just formed this
guy, and then I
perform against the
quintile of an F-test.
Notice, there's no
absolute value--
oh, yeah, I forgot,
this is actually
q alpha because the F-statistic
is already positive.
So I'm not going to look
between left and right,
I'm just going to look
whether it's too large or not.
So that's by definition.
So you can check--
if you look at a
table for student
and you look at a
table for F1q, one
it just going to-- you're going
to have to move from one column
to the other
because you're going
to have to move from
alpha over 2 to alpha,
but one is going to be
squared root of the other one,
just like the chi squared is
the square of the Gaussian.
I mean, if you look at the chi
squared 1 degree of freedom,
you will see the same
thing as the Gaussians.
So I'm actually going to
start with the last one
because you've been asking
a few questions about why
is my design deterministic.
So there's many answers.
Some are philosophical.
But one that's actually--
well, there's the one that says
everything you cannot do if
you don't have a condition--
if you don't have x, because all
of the statements that we made
here, for example, just the
fact that this is chi squared,
if those guys start to
be random variables,
then it's clearly not
going to be a chi squared.
I mean, it cannot be chi
squared when those guys are
deterministic and
when they are random.
I mean, things change.
So that's just maybe
[INAUDIBLE] check statement.
But I think the one that
really matters is that--
remember when we
did the t-test, we
had this gamma j that showed up.
Gamma j was playing the
role of the variance.
So here, the variance,
you never think of--
I mean, we'll talk about
this in the Bayesian setup,
but so far, we haven't
thought of the variance
as a random variable.
And so here, your x's really
are the parameters of your data.
And the diagonal elements
of x transpose x inverse
actually tell you
what the variance is.
So that's also one reason why
you should think of your x
as being a deterministic number.
They are, in a way,
things that change
the geometry of your problem.
They just say, oh,
let me look at it
from the perspective of x.
Actually, for that
matter, we didn't really
spend much time
commenting on what
is the effect of x onto gamma.
So remember, gamma j, so that
was the variance parameter.
So we should try to understand
what x's lead to big variance
and what x's lead
to small variance.
That would be nice.
Well, if this is the
identity matrix--
let's say identity over n,
which is the natural thing
to look at, because we want
this thing to scale like 1/n--
then this is just 1/n.
We're back to the original case.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't
that be inverse?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
thank you. x inverse, yes.
So if this is the identity,
then, well, the inverse
is-- let's say just this guy
here is n times this guy.
So then the inverse is 1/n.
So in this case, that means
that gamma j is equal to 1/n
and we're back to
the theta hat theta
case, the basic
one-dimensional thing.
What does it mean for a
matrix for when I take its--
yeah, so that's of dimension p.
But when I take its transpose--
so forget about the
scaling by n right now.
This is just a matter
of scaling things.
I can always multiply
my x's so that I
have this thing that shows up.
But when I have a matrix,
if I look at x transpose x
and I get something which
is the identity, how
do I call this matrix?
AUDIENCE: Orthonormal?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Orthogonal, yeah.
Orthonormal or orthogonal.
So you call this thing
an orthogonal matrix.
And when it's an orthogonal
matrix, what it means
is that the--
so this matrix here, if you
look at the matrix xx transpose,
the entries of this matrix
are the inner products
between the columns of x.
That's what's happening.
You can write it,
and you will see
that the entries of this
matrix are linear products.
If it's the identity, that
means that you get some 1's
and a bunch of 0's, it means
that all the inner products
between 2 different
columns is actually 0.
What it means is
that this matrix x
is an orthonormal
basis for your space.
The columns form an
orthonormal basis.
So they're basically as far
from each other as they can.
Now, if I start making those
guys closer and closer,
then I'm starting
to have some issues.
x transpose x is not
going to be the identity.
I'm going to start to
have some non-0 entries.
But if they all remain
of norm 1, then--
oh, sorry, so that's
for the inverse.
So I first start putting some
stuff here, which is non-0,
by taking my x's.
Rather than having
this, I move to this.
Now I'm going to start
seeing some non-0 entries.
And when I'm going to take
the inverse of this matrix,
the diagonal elements are
going to start to blow up.
Oh, sorry, the diagonals start
to become smaller and smaller.
So when I take the inverse--
no, sorry, the diagonal
limits are going to blow up.
And so what it means is that the
variance is going to blow up.
And that's essentially
telling you
that if you get to
choose your x's, you
want to take them as
orthogonal as you can.
But if you don't, then you
just have to deal with it,
and it will have a significant
impact on your estimation
performance.
And that's what, also,
routinely, statistical software
is going to spit out
this value here for you.
And you're going to have--
well, actually square
root of this value.
And it's going to tell
you, essentially--
you're going to know how much
randomness, how much variation
you have in this
particular parameter
that you're estimating.
So if gamma j is
large, then you're
going to have wide
confidence intervals
and your tests are not
going to reject very much.
And that's all captured by x.
That's what's important.
Everything, all of this, is
completely captured by x.
Then, of course, there
was the sigma squared
that showed up here.
Actually, it was here, even
in the definition of gamma j.
I forgot it.
What is the sigma
squared police doing?
And so this thing
was here as well,
and that's just exogenous.
It comes from the noise itself.
But there was this huge factor
that came from the x's itself.
So let's go back,
now, to reading
this list in a linear fashion.
So I mean, you're MIT
students, you've probably
heard that correlation does
not imply causation many times.
Maybe you don't
know what it means.
If you don't, that's OK, you
just have to know the sentence.
No, what it means
is that it's done
because I decided that
something was going to be the x
and that something
else was going
to be the y, that whatever
thing I'm getting,
it means that x implies y.
For example, even if I
do genetics, genomics,
or whatever, I
mean, I implicitly
assume that my genes
are going to have
an effect on my outside look.
I could be the opposite.
I mean, who am I to say?
I'm not a biologist.
I don't know.
I didn't open a biology
book in 20 years.
So maybe, if I start hitting
my head with a hammer,
I'm going to have changing
my genetic material.
Probably not, but that's why--
but causation definitely does
not come from statistics.
So if you know that that's
the different thing,
it's actually going to--
it's not coming from there.
So actually, I remember, once,
I put an exam to students,
and there was an old data
set from police expenditures,
I think, in Chicago in the '60s.
And they were trying
to understand--
no, it was on crime.
It was the crime data set.
And they were trying-- so
the y variable was just
the rate of crime, and the
x's were a bunch of things,
and one of them was
police expenditures.
And if you rend
the regression, you
would find that the coefficient
in front of police expenditure
was a positive
number, which means
that if you increase
police expenditures,
that increases the crime.
I mean, that's what it means
to have a positive coefficient.
Everybody agrees with this fact?
If beta j is 10, then it
means that if I increase by $1
my police expenditure, I
[INAUDIBLE] by 10 my crime,
everything else
being kept equal.
Well, there were,
I think, about 80%
of the students that were able
to explain to me that if you
give more money to
the police, then
the crime is going to raise.
Some people were
like, well, police
is making too much
money, and they
don't think about their
work, and they become lazy.
And I mean, people
were really coming up
with some crazy things.
And what it just meant is
that, no, it's not causation.
It's just, if you
have more crime,
you give more money
to your police.
That's what's happening.
And that's all there is.
So just be careful
when you actually
draw some conclusions that
causation is a very important
thing to keep in mind.
And in practice, unless you
have external sources of reason
for causality-- for
example, genetic material
and physical traits,
we agree upon what
the direction of the arrow
of causality is here.
There's places
where you might not.
Now, finally, the
normality on the noise--
everything we did today required
normal Gaussian distribution
on the noise.
I mean, it's everywhere.
There's some Gaussian,
there's some chi squared.
Everything came out of Gaussian.
And for that, we needed
this basic formula
for inference, which we
derived from the fact
that the noise was
Gaussian itself.
If we did not have that, the
only thing we could write
is, beta hat is this
number, or this vector.
We would not be able to say,
the fluctuations of beta hat
are this guy.
We would not be
able to do tests.
able to build, say,
confidence regions or anything.
And so this is an important
condition that we need,
and that's what statistical
software assumes by default.
But we now have a recipe
on how to do those tests.
We can do it either
visually, if we really
want to conclude that,
yes, this is Gaussian,
using our normal Q-Q plots.
And we can also do it
using our favorite tests.
What test should I be
using to test that?
With two names?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Normal [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Not the 2 Russians.
So I want a Russian and
a Scandinavian person
for this one.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Lillie-something?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, Lillie-something.
So Kolmogorov
Lillie-something test.
And [LAUGHS] so it's the
Kolmogorov Lilliefors test.
And because I'm testing if
there Gaussian, and I'm actually
not really making any--
I don't need to know
what the variance is.
The mean is 0.
We saw that at the beginning.
It's 0 by construction,
so we actually
don't need to think about
the mean being 0 itself.
This just happens to be 0.
So we know that it's 0, but
the variance, we don't know.
So we just want to
know if it belongs
to the family of Gaussians,
and so we need to Kolmogorov
Lilliefors for that.
And that's also one of the thing
that's spit out by statistical
software by default. When
you run a linear regression,
actually, it spits out
both Kolmogorov-Smirnov
and Kolmogorov Lilliefors,
probably contributing
to the widespread use of
Kolmogorov-Smirnov when you
really shouldn't.
So next time, we will talk
about more advanced topics
on regression.
But I think I'm going
to stop here for today.
So again, tomorrow,
sometime during the day,
at least before
the recitation, you
will have a list of practice
exercises that will be posted.
And if you go to the
optional recitation,
you will have
someone solving them